[Music]
dan bilzerian brand new house first time
we've seen in his new compound in vegas
[ __ ] let's see what it's all about
[Music]
so where are we we're in my house do a
little tour here when did you get this
place
and this is the start of the master
suite yeah these are all the dab rigs
for smoking concentrates how often do
you pause it pause it oh right away oh
my god
this is the master suite right yeah but
enough about that these are my dab rigs
imagine being like a 30 out of 10 woman
and you think you're about to like meet
like some like rich baller and he's just
exactly like a dude they met in college
oh my god daniel's hearing is this your
house yeah yeah come over here you gotta
come see this [ __ ] look at all my dab
rigs you gotta peep these dab rigs yeah
this one is based on shiva check it out
you inhale through her [ __ ]
sick you need to hit this
these are my bubblers
[Laughter]
three four times a day all the time like
i wouldn't even have sex unless i was
high so it was like
sick it was good sick dude
every time i was sober i puked when i
climbed man
bro pause it did you see that [ __ ] yeah
what was that was that a hummer that was
a rematch of his car yeah oh like the
three by three no no it was a hummer
yeah i don't know after i got this truck
i thought you know it's sick it's
everything i've ever wanted but how do i
smoke weed through it and so finally
this glass blind company made it happen
i have so many good memories of like
being in that truck and i wanted to
associate that with weed somehow so i
thought exactly it's like i've smoked in
the truck before but how do i smoke via
the truck when i dab through the hummer
i think it like
like i kind of imagine like like a small
me in there with like a bunch of small
chicks in there and we're all like hot
boxing in there and i picture me like
the god me like inhaling the hot box
from like the little me who's about to
have like a high foursome in there it's
pretty sick in my opinion it's pretty
trippy
the little me they're also smoking
a dab rig that looks like the hummer and
there's even littler versions of
them inside there
so it's basically the whole thing's like
we're living in a simulation you know
what i'm saying it's proof of that yeah
so i kind of got this idea when i was on
salvia having a ate some it was crazy
because i was like in i was like
inserted in one chick and then she had
like a strap on and she was like
dan bilzerian's voice is more like yeah
and i was [ __ ] this chick and then
she was [ __ ] another chick in front
of her and it was just like this long
train like chicks [ __ ] each other and
i was like
damn this all kind of starts with me
it's like
the human centipede you know except it's
my [ __ ] [ __ ] repeat
sorry oh yeah yeah let's move on it
pretty much all the time
pretty much
no i don't really man
[Music]
the bedroom hello what are you guys up
to today we're they're watching a movie
so let's let them watch the movie but
recovering
was last night fun
yo stop stop stop stop
this [ __ ] reporter yeah yeah how was
last night no i know what a dweeb
so what are you guys up to what the [ __ ]
do you think they're doing dude
recovering
that's [ __ ] i hate how he talks about
them like children that's like they're
called leadership right there they're
watching a movie let's let them okay
okay stop talking to them let's let's
let them watch their movie they're
recovering
yeah dork mode 200.
did you have a good time
you ladies are beautiful
i'm [ __ ] pissed we have to watch this
through
doodoo quality because i know just every
aspect of this is so funny oh wait till
this part right here this is so good
he's got all that military [ __ ] but he
has you know he's got those neon shorts
he's got to make sure he has his neon
shorts man just wait till where do you
see what he what he's got like
in bulk on his counter here play it for
a family of people or a guy that doesn't
wear the same thing every day
that's the wardrobe right there you're
looking at it it's my finest cat there
oh how many cats do you have got two and
you've always been
a cat guy i do okay
i do work
you said positive you said i do
that's that's the thing i was talking
about look at how many chlamydia and
gonorrhea tests he's got on here oh my
god bro
oh my god so you've always been a cat
guy huh i do i do
what a alpha thing to do
just answering the wrong context that's
[ __ ] sick i feel like that was him
like preemptively answering like so are
you always thinking of [ __ ] i do i do
always been a cat guy
we gotta do a shirt with that on it i do
always been okay i love how
condescending all of his answers have to
be uh you could tell he's already fed up
with this guy four questions in yeah
this uh this uh closet look like it's
for a whole family yeah regatta doesn't
wear the same [ __ ] thing every day
wow chlamydia and gonorrhea tests yeah
this is this is for when you have sex i
do always been a chlamydia and
gonorrhoea okay i'll always be testing
myself
it actually is so it's so funny daniel's
aaron's like you're in high school or
something like that you know you have a
condom in your wallet just so you can
like open it and be like oh [ __ ]
yeah man yeah i keep it i keep it on me
you know never know when you might have
sex he's like [ __ ] this news reporter's
coming over okay i got to leave a bunch
of [ __ ] around that makes it look like
i'm cool who left these in there i told
the housekeeper to hide these yeah i
have sex literally this much so he hires
an assistant to get like an industrial
box of condoms and then unwrap them all
yeah just leave the like just leave the
wrappers all throughout the house we
need to make sure he thinks i [ __ ] in
every room it's crucial magnums run it
back a few seconds so like the stream
can catch up and then i and i need to
see that i do again the wardrobe right
there you're looking at it
it's my finest cat there
how many cats do you have got two and
you've always been
a cat guy i do okay
dogs are a lot of work you have a
chlamydia test
a syphilis test you gotta check out a
check with a syphilis
an hiv test
i mean it's all blood work dude the
whole thing
all right so how often are you doing
these probably every two months really
yeah how long have you been doing that
for
10 years something i mean i get
everything it's like you know your test
levels your hgh your estrogen like the
whole thing so that's like fine-tuning a
race car when you start with your
hormones you really gotta like watch you
know a lot of people just do cycles and
they're not monitoring but when you
monitor you can like really you know
just get everything perfect
he's quiet
yeah well about 18
shots in yeah they quieted me down a
little bit
uh what just happened in there i think
he said so what's my man dan here like
what's my friend dan here like to party
with huh she sounded like she was mid
[ __ ]
like he just admitted to doing steroids
too that's pretty yeah yeah just
casually like you know oh man you know
yeah when you're when you're on as much
[ __ ] as i am
it's like fine-tuning a race car it's
like fine-tuning an h2 yeah blowing
blowing gas through an h2 it's like
fine-tuning a 3x3 brabus
that's so crazy to just get up one day
and in your closet
are just like cereal boxes of
blood blood work exams yeah
you